hey guys i'm off the grid for august and
here's joe rogan making some sense and
maybe it'll trickle up to the mainstream
you never know yeah nothing and no
accountability no accountability for
these decisions that show no there was
no science john hopkins comes out of the
study talking about these lockdowns into
more detriment than than good yeah you
know and and they're not the only you
know
research
place that's done these these type of
studies but but are they gonna go back
and reverse and they say oh oh tough
[ __ ] sorry
because i think on one level it's really
one of two extremes right either they
really thought they were doing the right
thing
or
there's some coordinated plan
maybe it's somewhere i don't think
there's a coordinated plan i think
people were trying i'm just saying what
people think right well i have a friend
and his brother works for the covid
response whatever it is in california
and you remember when they had made a
decision to close outdoor dining
and it turned out that one of the people
that made that decision the day she did
it went out and was dining outdoors i
thought you meant gavin newsom going oh
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah that was fun
um this was a different one but uh
he had a statement he was like with what
they were talking he said but well dude
what evidence is there that it spread in
outdoor dining and she said it's about
optics
so this was a decision that this
politician had decided to make this
bureaucrat decided to make
to show that they're doing something
because the numbers had gone up so we're
going to start this stop outdoor dining
which showed zero transmission there was
no cases they were connecting to outdoor
dining it does it especially in the
early days of code i think they've
they've since revised that with omicron
apparently is so contagious and some of
the new strains are more contagious and
they think there may be some instances
of uh outdoor spread but that was not
the case back then joe they closed the
beaches in california
yeah they closed the beaches
yeah
where i live in california
and all along the coast oh yeah remember
that one guy who was getting arrested by
the coast guard because he was a paris
airliner or something no he was uh
surfing yeah he was surfing
the coast guard you're out there by
yourself yeah on a surfboard they're
supposed to be stopping terrorists
passing copa to the dolphins or what
come on what are we doing it's so dumb
but you know i hope there's lessons
learned in this because this is a new
thing we had never had this before no
you know no one who is alive today had
ever experienced a true pandemic
and i'm hoping that now that this is
over people are going to
you know recognize that some serious
errors were made and not repeat those
that's the best you can get out of it
but as far as compensation for all those
people that were forced to close their
businesses and keep their doors
shuttered and lost everything that
they'd worked for decades to build
no they're they're just going to be
angry so what do you tell those people
vote republican
that's what a lot of them are going to
do anyway yeah yeah oh yeah i mean more
than a million people transferred over
to the republican party
uh i think in 2021 alone find out what
that number is
but you know you look at guys like ron
desantis who kept florida open and and
had some pretty reasonable policies in
terms of like what what to do about
covet and you know he mapped it out on
television he was
you know widely criticized for this
where he was saying like we need to
protect our elders we need to you know
make sure that medical care is available
for those people and everyone else you
should be able to do whatever you want
to do protect your freedom
isn't that the point though i think to
learn from this is yeah here it is more
than one million voters switched the gop
raising alarms for democrats [ __ ] you
think
a political shift is beginning to hold
across the u.s as tens of thousands of
suburban swing voters who helped
fuel the democratic party's gains in
recent years of becoming republicans